this is evan langer reading for reviewer
steven petit kirby has reached his
ultimate form in kirby in the forgotten
land as the culmination of 30 plus years
of exploring the malleable mascot his
latest adventure is the most inventive
and best entry in the franchise history
the move to 3d brings kirby's signature
mechanic to life in a way that wasn't
possible before
this feels like a new beginning for
kirby as it maintains all of the
familiar series trappings while
presenting them in a cohesive
well-rounded adventure that is playfully
imaginative throughout
kirby in the forgotten land follows the
traditional stage based format with
multiple areas and rooms in each area
it's certainly not as open as the
trailers have made it seem it's much
closer to super mario 3d world than
super mario odyssey still the stages
hold far more secrets than might
initially meet the eye actively
encouraging you to poke around to find
hidden rooms paths and areas with
self-contained objectives containing
their own rewards at the end though
forgotten land mostly sticks with the
tried and true world themes we've come
to expect from nintendo platformers the
remnants of civilizations present in the
forgotten land give these locales
mysterious vibes that make them unique
from an abandoned shopping mall an
amusement park to a haunted house and
chile metro station each of forgotten
land's 30 plus stages tell their own
story unlike some other recent kirby
games it almost always feels fresh and
full of new ideas
[Music]
this consistent novel charm is
significantly bolstered by the
meaningful use of kirby's copy mechanic
and the brand new mouthful mode the meme
worthy feature isn't a silly gimmick
it's a delightful and interesting
gameplay mechanic that also happens to
be quite funny kirby can only absorb the
powers of living things so when he tries
to inhale inanimate objects he just
stretches his body around them watching
him swallow other characters and take on
their attributes was a lot to deal with
already but now we have to embrace the
chaos that is kirby inhaling cars
commandeering roller coasters and
revolutionizing the aerodynamics of
paragliding
[Music]
each mouthful ability has its own unique
mechanic and is often used to complete
bonus objectives and rescue hidden
waddle dees
the abilities up the gameplay in
creative ways coaster mouth sees kirby
do his best ratchet rail grind
impression ring mouth can knock out
enemies with powerful gusts or be used
to steer a boat and water balloon mouth
turns kirby into a giant blob who spews
water clearing fiery obstacles and
sludge while laying ways to colossal
obstacles that cannot be taken out with
normal copy abilities meanwhile the
sparsely used light bulb mouth assists
with the pitch black haunted house where
cardboard monsters pop out from the
walls and ghost chase the illuminated
kirby bulb mouthful mode shines but
kirby's signature copy ability is still
front and center and more important than
ever before unlike some other kirby
platformers kirby's various copy
abilities are consistently meaningful
from both a puzzle solving and combat
perspective
there are switches that have to be hit
in quick succession with the cutter by
performing a combo move ice blocks that
require fire to melt fiery crates that
need the cooling power of ice floating
targets for ranged weapons nails for the
hammer etc even some of the platforming
sequences are designed with specific
abilities in mind including large gaps
that can only be crossed with the
tornado ability or surfaces that call
for kirby to glide like a figure skater
with the ice ability the 3d perspective
itself is also beneficial to kirby's
abilities as it makes them versatile and
leads to more creative puzzles
experimentation and open-ended
objectives
[Music]
so
while forgotten land likely won't be a
difficult game for those with some
experience with action platformers it is
the most challenging kirby to date it
has two difficulty settings with the
more challenging wild mode boasting some
tricky boss battles that require you to
think about your strategy when it comes
to copy abilities
that said forgotten land is still
inviting to newcomers thanks to the
forgiving spring breeze mode and the
ability to buy health items or attack or
defense boosts blueprints earned by
beating bosses or solving hidden puzzles
can be turned in to evolve copy
abilities hal laboratory did a great job
gradually ramping up the difficulty
alongside your expected ability upgrades
evolved copy abilities deal greater
damage while having additional features
that can expand their versatility in
combat you also need rare stones to
purchase evolve copy abilities these are
earned through optional side stages on
treasure road fun time trials that
revolve around a specific copy ability
or mouthful mode treasure road stages
are bite-sized compared to main levels
but they are well designed and a lot of
fun which is great considering there are
more of these than main levels
[Music]
[Applause]
the main stages and treasure road levels
add up to create a 10 to 15 hour
platformer depending on how thorough you
want to be
copyability upgrades and item purchases
are made in waddle d-town the game's
central hub that expands as you rescue
more waddle dees the town includes a
coliseum for boss rush gauntlets and a
few mini-games including the motion
sensor tilt and roll that nods back to
the game boy color game tilt and tumble
and reflex base fishing and cooking
games
[Music]
you can also spend coins at the gacha
machine to try and collect all the
figures beware there are a lot of
figures and all they do is sit in a
digital album the activities of waddle
d-town aren't that engaging but they're
essentially just cute little add-ons
rather than focal points
[Music]
for parents with young kids the local
co-op mode is a blast even though one
player has to be the decidedly less cool
bandana waddle d who can't steal
abilities from enemies while he's the
coolest waddle d due to the bandana the
second player doesn't get to partake in
the most interesting aspects of each
stage this is most notable during
mouthful sections as bandana waddle d
has to rely on kirby to do his thing to
move on to the next section it's a
better co-op mode than some other
family-friendly switch exclusives but
the experience playing as waddle d isn't
nearly as dynamic when you're stuck with
one set of attacks while kirby has
dozens
kirby in the forgotten land is one of
those games that's hard to play without
constantly having a silly smile on your
face it's far more than just a cute and
charming platformer with colorful
visuals though this is one of the best
platformers on nintendo switch thanks to
its brilliantly designed stages and a
dynamic arsenal of abilities that
consistently shake up the
moment-to-moment platforming and action
[Music]
bye